there are so many events and initiatives
and programs that are happening with
alumni around the world we have over 80
regional clubs we have planned over 165
programs this year and there is so much
energy and enthusiasm and we are just
looking forward to another great year at
Columbia the sense of unity and pride to
be part of the Columbia family is what
the CAA represents and strengthens
bringing together alumni across the
university and around the world to all
of you who are alumni leaders in so many
different ways thanks for all you do to
connect alum Colombians with each other
and with the university now I'd like to
introduce you to our first panel when we
were planning this assembly is a
schedule schedule we thought it would be
important for alumni who serve as
Colombia ambassadors to learn from
university leaders what's on the horizon
and what roles alumni can play in
shaping Colombia's future so please join
me in welcoming today's insider view of
the University panelists our moderator
Robert Kasdan senior executive vice
president Susan Fagan a fellow alum from
the school of general studies executive
vice president for university
development and alumni relations Joe I
Anu so a graduate of the business school
executive vice president for Columbia
University facilities and nerve narvekar
president of the Columbia investment
management company thank you for joining
us today